so let's say that i have matrix a and
it's elements it's a 2x2 a b
c d
we have a lot of practice taking
determinants of matrices like this
the determinant
of this matrix
same thing as the determinant of a b c d
it's going to be equal to a times d a d
minus b times c
now what would happen if we multiply one
row of this matrix by a constant what
would happen to its determinant
well let's try it out
so you have your original the
determinant of your original matrix a
b
c
d
i'm just rewriting what i just did up
here that's a d
minus bc
now if i were to multiply let's say this
first row by a constant k
how would that change the determinant
well instead of this being just an a
this is now a k a
instead of this being just a b it is now
a k b
and so this is equal to k
times
a d
minus b c
which is the same thing
as it's equal to k
times our original determinant of our
matrix a
so that seems pretty interesting and i
encourage you to see that if you instead
of doing the first row you did the
second row you would have gotten the
same outcome and then you can also
verify that look if i multiply both of
these rows by that constant k
how would that change things
well then i'm going to have ka times kd
so you're going to have a k squeezed in
there and then you're going to have k b
times k c
and so this would actually be you could
factor out a k squared and so this is
going to be k squared times the
determinant of a and that can be
extended to a generalized property that
if i have some
n by n matrix a
then
the determinant
the determinant of
k
times that n by n
matrix a
the determinant of this when i multiply
a constant times a entire matrix i'm
multiplying that constant times all the
rows you could say all of the elements
well this is going to be equal to pause
this video see if you can
intuit what this general formula is
going to be
you might be tempted to say it's k times
the determinant of a but remember that's
only if i multiply one row by k but if i
multiply the entire matrix by k well
then this is going this determinant is
going to be the constant k
to the nth power
times the determinant of our n by n
matrix a
and you could see this play out in a
three by three case in fact i encourage
you to try it out with some three by
threes and you could also do a
generalized proof for an n by n case but
i won't do that now this is really just
to give you the idea